women will tend to go for things like
being a nurse being a teacher they pay a
lot less than being financed correct yes
yes but the pay Gap then exists in so a
lot of things where there's a lot of
male actors who will be like I will not
uh sign on to this contract unless I
know my female counterparts are being
paid the same and so I think the pay Gap
then comes and well it's also the truth
it's also the trait like disagreeable
though so as women like we're naturally
more agreeable 100 so so we're I'm more
I'm terrible at negotiating I just want
to make everyone happy and I just want
to be like yeah I'll do whatever for
nothing and but that's like men are more
disagreeable if you look at the
agreeability scale does that make sense
yeah yeah so again like why do we just
assume patriarchy when you don't know if
it's because of different personality
traits and gender differences